hey guys my name is Joey and once again
we have some injustice to gameplay for
you all this one's coming from
NetherRealm stream where they
highlighted Wonder Woman's moveset and
gear options any comic book outfits
you'd like to see make it into the game
let me know in the comments and be sure
to subscribe for more injustice 2 videos
uh what woman is a lot different than a
justice one and justice one she was
split this you stance that it was a very
power yeah she had lots of stairs was a
high mobility jack-of-all-trades kind of
she will do a little bit of everything
and then there was sort stands like a up
close rush down just good animation you
nail it
yeah merry Christmas from a late season
right in this one uh we kind of combined
we kind of took the best of both kind of
the greatest Hinson twenty together and
made her more of a warrior I guess what
I mean you look at her her whole deal is
this she's like one of the best warriors
needles and having to switch between
different types of being warrior maybe
doesn't fit her character as well and
now it's all put together right yeah
she's a returning character that he
plays similar to how she did before yes
she she still has the soul to stop she's
behind her back to three which is a
great overhead attack with a lot of
range 600 and casting down to in the
jumping and she still had straighten up
attack right right
we seen a lot more of those later I
heard nimac with vog wandering player
you know I think was mute this guy oh I
thought he Catwoman player
what do you first started in QA you
played it home I did I did I am in this
one she has a bunch of new strings that
work in either stance that he has
I won't push you away that's a big class
of attack now could you do that from a
distance in the lasso shuttle attacks
Wow that's for me that's pretty awesome
so she's kind of like a half a new
character it is interesting if I played
her and I felt like I played a little
the one with a person okay I still feel
like your game plan is there yet but it
just you get they're different yeah I I
agree please calm and then Center
character power to the winner switching
do you have a brand new one seems like
Harley here and it is a blessing from
the God is the character power button
and she did say [ __ ] and she had five
different clubs that she can do and it's
randomly chose so she's got a he and
each of her weapons could be one with
his meat labid oh sorry
he's seen everything wrong today about
he said I got his dogs thinking about
where I get it I get her on this love
all her laughs of it back they do
morning she has her boots which is one
of those interesting this actually gives
are actually pretty right
and then it turns our back into the high
mobility chair there's a booth glass
shield is another interesting one it
thought was damaged when it shows axe
and it also makes her she lost the other
projectiles the property where they
shooter projectile and then she can fill
out their projectile will be nullified
Egyptian capital okay so what so what
this character power really does is that
you have to really be thinking on your
feet
yes because whatever like you to be a
real master of Wonder Woman breasts
because whatever trade you get you're
gonna need to want to kind of slip into
that mindset a little bit and the great
thing is they last a long time and the
recharge was pretty quick yeah watch the
recharge it's actually very bad mood not
meant to be a buff that you kind of use
in your absolute desperate this is meant
to be something that you're turning on
throughout the match multiple times and
like Tyler said we'd like to see
everyone like a dub on the clock and
maybe maybe you get a buff that you
can't use a point where you're at well
writing if you can go through and start
it again
well yeah but generally like it the way
she plays it her foots too
in her spacing a lot of these are gonna
be pretty useful wherever you are
yeah and so well just real quick as well
um what some of the returning specialist
yes
well she has her she'll talk back and
like before it's a really good table
starting here money come back her
straight laughs I was back cuz she
forced him to tell the truth on a meter
broom she does hard from RE I don't
wanna member still do the air talk the
air shield shield Street hanger field
and then on she has her shield bash from
part one which is a really good school
to get a close folks again especially me
to burn can read my reviews if you meter
burn it it's actually safe on block so
the mix-up would be another kind of many
game would be the regular one is
punishable but at times makes me want to
respect it and if you don't want to take
any risk of severe burn it and it's one
of the meter removed and your freedom
meter burn at any time I did see some
stuff on chat where people are like oh
my that damage that damage all that
stuff isn't sent yeah we're I mean these
are these are still you know well yeah
that's okay um then she has a huge she
has upward she'll back which is really
cool because if it misses or its blogs
you can come down with this quick
overhead attack but if it hit it goes
and do this aircraft so good evening do
this like so like you knows like if one
is coming in right there you go yeah
brutal and so there's all kind of setups
with that you can you know go over there
on purpose and then come down quickly
problems with
you can use it infer to extend Commons
in the corner cool hey super I'm Anthony
people really cool and throw Raju I
guess committed I don't think we've seen
Idol it's pretty throw pretty quick ten
point yeah oh good line and I forgot one
of her best normal it 14-3 with
different it's a low combo starter it's
kind of a high-risk high-reward common
star and that compliment for that get
off now yeah the low is excluded fast
that is like right out like off of it
which is where that's where the money is
at the convoy I've been working on that
I will drop later most likely probably
have a little me I do I do
alright let's check out I made a guy on
reddit wanted to see some some cool
color stuff so I really really up to up
the ante a little bit with Wonder Woman
so I have some cool stuff I picked up
and so I have some really cool abilities
misalign neighbors all right let me go
ahead and bring up its allure
okay he would awesome but yeah look at
that it's a pretty awesome new good
appear in China so this is called a
vendor shield
yeah glaring awful so this is called a
sort of a Cena it's a low sit with me to
burn can pop up into a wall combo just
do 3 min
ooh he just told you what to do told me
earlier all right you trying to use
trying to get tricky there we go
yeah so that's a low a very fast low
combo starter and that will replace the
shield bash right oh yeah that'll play
back okay okay I you think about I have
to yeah and that that's one of the
things we're loadouts are so important
yeah I think about that okay cool
also the air Amazonian slam boom this is
kind of reminiscent of her hair Dada the
first one it is very very bad mechanic
commuter vertigo image so it's the same
basic concept as the ground shield bash
bug you know obviously it's a dichotomy
right very fast very damaging and then I
continue to jump bar to the moment you
know your jump three right awesome
alright yeah really cool-looking gear
set she has for this one too yes a black
and black and red really got jr. 3d on
the next one that I've chosen for the
gear is my favorite color pattern that
she has for me like I really enjoy it
the blue gold and white and you super
cool and this one we add in a mouthiest
protection which is a walking shield
move this one's really um if the shield
in turn its of armor and watch so Wonder
Woman um she does every still talks
about me prints projects out looks you
get kind of struggle against Sony and
this would be a perfect load up okay and
she can actually me or Burton them and
once it's Peterburg she take them to
sodium it's just code it's a walking
tank yes and also to like you can notice
the different shields that we also have
ya know many unique pieces of gear for
the accessories for each one of the
characters you know we've talked about a
little bit yeah the accessory slot for
each character is kind of their their
personality piece almost sure and like
we saw the last one had that sort of
triangular looking sort of shield so
there's a lot of really cool stuff
Harley's guns yet a lot of really cool
stuff on there
in porn there's one like a old school
like the group met like Revolutionary
Wars yeah and then of course also in
this one she has the lasso stick oh good
wake up yeah a great wake up attack a
great anti-air back it's multiple
knitting this also replaces the upward
shield back so yes this is long which
offer now that they're moving this one
is not as damaging it's not as a mere
person but it is a morbid upward angle
so what would depend on your palm for
money cool excellent anything else uh
one would notice basically is you want
to do a swaggy combo you go this way you
can't even do oh he hands me over to
Tyler Linda how many tries my thing is
going to get it on her third try we
retry okay a little left Chat Chat I
have a combo I'm gonna do well how I'm
gonna they don't get me friend okay I
have a calm moment to do chat how many
times is it going to take me how many go
sir somebody said 30
ah one runner that's one oh you got it
oh okay that's the easiest part well
there okay that's two mystery right
after my hands are sweating
ah I walked for it didn't work for it
got dibs
that's four that was three I was very
more every is this boy well warm up once
again yes Oh a little we're getting
worse
okay ah there we go
took me a couple times goomy hold on but
uh yeah so that's that's my sweet that's
the compliment I love to do I did eight
times in a row yesterday okay I did it
one time in anybody oh man thorough
everyone's talking about it everybody it
was going around the studio that time
unity yeah it was it was big news if
again that's amazing alright
[Music]
Oh
[Music]